>> WALL PUTIN'S WAR HAS INSPIRED
MOST AMERICANS TO PUT ASIDE
THEIR POLITICAL DIFFERENCES AND
UNITE BEHIND THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE, IT IS NOT STOPPED SOME
PROGRESSIVE ABUNDANCE FROM TYING
THE WORD TO YOU DOMESTIC AND SHE
IS.
>> TODAY THE AVERAGE GAS PRICE
IN AMERICA HIT AN ALL-TIME
RECORD HIGH OF OVER $4 PER
GALLON.
I'LL PAY $15 PER GALLON BECAUSE
I DRIVE A TEST FLOW.
>> PERHAPS IF YOU LET THE MARKET
WHERE PEOPLE WILL FEEL PAIN,
THEY WILL THEY WILL TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AT THAT GIGANTIC
TRUCK.
>> WE HAVE TO MOVE TO CLEAN
ENERGY SOLUTIONS.
IT'S WHERE WE SHOULD BE SO THAT
WE DON'T FIND OURSELVES IN THIS
POSITION AGAIN.
>> STEPHEN COLBERT WHERE WILLING
TO PAY $15 A YEAR FOR GAS, I'M
SURE HE IS IN THE MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR SALARY.
JOHN KERRY ALSO SING THE GAS
PRICES IS NOTHING COMPARED TO
OUR FUTURE CLIMATE CHANGE
PROBLEM.
>> IF YOU THINK MIGRATION HAS
BEEN A PROBLEM IN EUROPE FOR THE
SYRIAN WAR AND FROM WHAT WE'VE
SEEN NOW.
WAIT TILL YOU SEE A HUNDRED
MILLION PEOPLE, FOR WHOM THE
ENTIRE FOOD PRODUCTION CAPACITY
HAS COLLAPSED.
>> YOU NEVER LETS A CRISIS GO TO
WASTE.
IS IT ALL ABOUT CLIMATE?
>> YES, IT IS.
THEY ARE BEING HONEST, THEY
WELCOME THE PAIN.
THEY WANT THE PRICES.
NOW THEY NEED TO WRAP IT IN A
SO-CALLED PATRIOTIC DUTY.
IT'S LIKE A NEW MASK, IT'S LIKE
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO VIRTUE
SIGNAL WITH THE UKRAINIAN FLAG
WAS SIGNED BY THE WAY, BUT GAS
PRICES ARE AT $6 AND IT'S ALL
PUTIN'S FAULT.
AS A RESULT, YOU SHOULD BUY INTO
THE GREEN NEW FANTASY.
IT'S THOSE VERY FANTASIES THEY
CREATED A KIND OF DEPENDENCY WE
ARE IN RIGHT NOW WHICH HAVE LED
TO THAT.
IT'S EXACTLY WHO THEY ARE AND
WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
>> THEY WANT YOU TO PAY MORE.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE PAYING $15
FOR GAS -- I KNOW IT'S LIKE FOUR
OR $5, BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY
THAT.
WE CAN EMBARGO RUSSIAN OIL AND
UNLEASHED DOMESTIC ENERGY.
THAT IS NOT GREAT MESSAGING FROM
STEPHEN COLBERT.
>> WELL YOU KNOW, KAYLEIGH, THE
LIBERAL ELITE ECHO CHAMBER IS
DEAFENING.
IT IS DROWNING OUT THESE CRIES
AND COMPLAINTS FROM AMERICANS
WHO ARE SAYING I CAN AFFORD YOUR
POLICY.
I DON'T WANT YOUR POLICY.
YOUR POLICY IS CRIPPLING MY
POCKETBOOK, MY BUSINESS, MY
COMMUNITY, MY LOCAL ECONOMY.
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE MIDTERMS,
THEY WILL PAY FOR THAT.
ALL OF THIS AT THE END OF THE
DAY FOR DEMOCRATS IS JUST DUMB
TRYING TO GET THEIR POLICIES
THROUGH.
NOW HERE WE ARE WITH GAS AND
FOREIGN POLICY, THIS IS ALL
ABOUT GETTING THEIR SOCIALIST
AGENDA THROUGH AND AMERICANS
AREN'T BUYING IT.
IT'S HURTING US.
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
FEEL THE PAIN, THERE IS A POLL
THAN THE LAST DAY OR SO, 50% OF
AMERICANS SAY INFLATION IS THEIR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN RIGHT
APPEARED AS LONG AS DEMOCRATS
TRY TO MAKE THIS ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE THEY WILL LOSE NOT JUST
HEARTS AND MINDS, BUT THE VOTE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS WELL.
>> NO DOUBT.
>> UKRAINE IS SHOWN A PRETTY
RADICAL DISPARITY ABOUT HOW WITH
SOME REPORTERS USING VERY
TELLING COMPARISONS IN THEIR
ANALYSIS OF THE WAR.
>> I MEAN, CARLY, WHY?
>> I CAN BELIEVE I HAVE TO
EXPLAIN THIS BUT THIS IS A WAR
ABOUT AN ATTACK ON 43
INNOCENT -- 43 MILLION INNOCENT
PEOPLE BEING ATTACKED BY FORMER
KGB MADMAN WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THERE WAS ALSO A SIMILAR
DISCUSSION THAT GAYLE KING HAD
ON HER SHOW WHERE THEY STARTED
TO TALK ABOUT HOW UKRAINIAN
REFUGEES ARE BEING TREATED
BETTER THAN PEOPLE CROSSING OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, TRYING TO MAKE
OUR COUNTRY SEEM RACIST AND
UNWELCOMING.
THEN EXPLAIN HOW WE WERE SO
WELCOMING WHEN AFGHAN REFUGEES
WERE COMING INTO OUR CONTRIBUTE
NOT OF THING HAS TO BE ABOUT
RACE.
EDITING HAS TO BE ABOUT
AMERICA'S EVIL IN THIS WAR
CERTAINLY AN EXAMPLE OF NOT
FITTING THE BILL IN THAT REGARD.
BUT FOR LIBERALS OF COURSE
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE ABOUT
TRUMP.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHOOPI GOLDBERG.
>> WAS SOME BONEHEAD HAVE BEEN
PRESENT -- I'M SAYING WHAT I
SAID LAST TIME NO, THERE
WOULDN'T BEEN ANY ISSUE.
BECAUSE THAT GUY WOULD'VE HANDED
UKRAINE OVER TO THE RUSSIANS.
>> EXCEPT WE HAD A FOUR-YEAR
TERM OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THERE WAS NO INVASION.
THE BIG LAST TIME I CHECKED THIS
INVASION HAPPENED UNDER SOMEONE
ELSE'S WATCH.
THAT'S ONE MORE EXAMPLE TO ME AS
WELL OF MINIMIZING WHAT IS
OCCURRING IN THAT SITUATION AND
THEN WE HAVE THAT SAME EXPLOSIVE
HYPERBOLIC RHETORIC ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS HERE.
SO WE HAD MSNBC HOST, TRUCK
DOCUMENTS THAT HE WAS STUNNED
WHEN THE PRESIDENT GAVE HIS
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
HIS FAILURE TO ESSENTIALLY
EQUATE THE FIGHT FOR DEMOCRACY
AND FREEDOM ABROAD, TO CONNECT
IT FOR THE FIGHT DEMOCRACY AND
FREEDOM AT HOME.
PROBABLY BECAUSE THERE IS
NOTHING SIMILAR ABOUT THE TWO.
HERE POINT, CARLY COME I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT ONE IS
FACING AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS
MINIMIZE A MINUTE WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR ESCALATION INTO A
GLOBAL WAR.
THEN ONE IS ABOUT DEMOCRATS
CRYING ABOUT REPUBLICAN RAMPANT
SUPPRESSION OF VOTES.
I MEAN IT'S ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS TO THINK THAT THE
CONNECTION OF THOSE TWO WOULD BE
IN ANY WAY LOGICAL.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FROM THE
LEFT AND THAT'S WHA